what's the last thing you remember
daddy he said we had to round the reason
you survived it's because you're a very
uncommon girl you're not alone not
anymore
do you know a mutants or would anyone
like you she had their first time brain
I was 13 I thought it was a dream I just
lost control Sam I started panicking
people got hurt
Roberto my girlfriend Julianna
I killed 18 men one by
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
it's important we find out your cover so
we can help you get better I saw
something
I don't think you wanted me to see
I don't think we're here to cut better
this place takes your greatest fear
it makes your way through it until it
kills you is there we can get out of
this together
[Applause]
[Music]
how's it going everybody its Lauren and
as you just saw the New Mutants trailer
is officially here there's a lot of new
footage to talk about and breakdown so
let's get right into it so to start off
let's just clear up some confusion right
away this was originally supposed to
connect with the x-men in the Fox
universe in x-men apocalypse we had the
post-credits scene of mr. Sinister's
people from Essex showing up and
stealing Weapon X's blood this was all
supposed to connect and it was supposed
to eventually set up mr. sinister
however this is now a Marvel film and
will not connect with the x-men so in
this new trailer we actually learn a lot
more about the film than we knew before
we see all of the main characters in a
mental institution allow every we
learned that it's not really a hospital
we here Illyana Rasputin aka Magic say
this isn't a hospital it's a cage and in
this trailer we actually learned that
the main villain of New Mutants is demon
bear now demon bear is a specific New
Mutants villain he first appeared in New
Mutants 3 and the new mutants are
primarily the people who fight him and
what's most likely going on from what we
saw and heard in this trailer is that
demon bear is most likely shape-shifting
their reality in this mental institution
the director of this movie describes the
film as a horror film but it's also a
rubber reality type of film where the
main characters don't know what reality
is real and what is being manipulated so
we go through the trailer and we see and
we hear each of the New Mutants origin
stories but what is happening is that
their origin stories are being
manipulated by black bear to actually be
their greatest fear and that is
primarily what is happening in this
trailer that's why we see hands and we
see faces coming through walls that's
why we see everybody talking about and
we're not meant to get out of this place
it shows you your greatest fear until
your greatest fear eventually kills you
and the character demon bear feeds off
of negative emotion which is most likely
why he's doing all this and trapped the
New Mutants in this hospital the nurse
or doctor in this film is actually
Cecilia Reyes and she's actually an
x-men and a good person in the comics
and she is a doctor and a surgeon in the
comics as well and what's most likely
happening here is that the demon bear
has probably trapped her too and is
manipulating her as well because that's
one of his abilities corruption of the
human soul essentially letting him
control people so she's most likely
still a good person in this video but
most likely being controlled by
demon bear her abilities are force
filled generation around herself so will
most likely see that at some point in
time in New Mutants now ultimately the
New Mutants go on to realize that
they're being trapped in this new horror
reality created by demon bear and we
finally see each of the New Mutants
powers in this trailer we start off with
Wolfsbane or Rafe Sinclair now in this
trailer we see her struggle with her
religious beliefs which is why we see
her in a church she's struggling with
her beliefs and the fact that she's a
mutant she can turn into a wolf so when
we see a her segment of sort of this
horror reality created for her by demon
bear we see her in a church then we have
cannon ball or Sam gun three and most of
you can probably recognize this actor
from stranger things
cannonball has the ability to fly at the
speed of a jet and he does this by
creating an impenetrable force field
around himself and we see him do this a
couple of times in the trailer and then
we have sunspot or Roberto babi de Costa
and he has the ability to absorb and
manipulate solar energy and we see it
done a few times in this trailer and it
actually looks really really good they
did a good job with it then we have
Mirage or Danny moon star and she
actually has powers quite similar to
demon bear she has the psychic ability
to create illusions of her opponents
fears and wishes she also has a really
wide range of psionic and energy
manipulation powers and then we have
magic or Illyana Rasputin and she is
actually the younger sister of the x-men
Colossus and she has a whole slew of
powers that we see in this trailer she
has the ability to teleport and
inter-dimensionally teleport which we
see in this trailer and just like her
name magic she has the ability to use
sorcery and magic and each time she uses
magic of the more and more she creates
what's called the eldritch armor this is
armor that forms around her and gets
stronger the more she uses magic which
we see in this trailer and then of
course we see her wielding the soul
sword at the end fighting demon bear the
soul sword is literally made from her
soul it doesn't really have any physical
effect but it does get stronger each
time she uses it and what it does is
basically disrupt magic and psychic
abilities which is why we see her at the
end with the soul sword in her hand
fighting demon bear she's trying to
break this reality that he's created
with her soul sword Antonio Banderas is
supposed to be in the movie he's
supposed to be the main villain so he's
probably playing demon bear unless he's
truly not the main villain and they do
plan on introducing mr. sinister
although that plan is
probably not going to happen now that
this is a Marvel film but that's the New
Mutants trailer let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below do you like it are you excited are
you going to go see it don't forget to
like the video and subscribe when
notifications turned on so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or ps4 the winner will be picked at
five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof